one of the games I love playing with my
kids is risk risk is a game about trying
to take over the world in this case I've
got two people playing two armies the
blue Army and the white Army each time
you will get more people that you can
place on the countries um and the number
of countries you have generate more uh
armies for you to lay down if you
control a continent then you also get
more armies so if you actually control
the whole of Europe like white does you
generate um five extra pieces to be able
to lay down on your next go um Asia
which is a very big area generates seven
um America you see blue controls the
American side you actually generate five
when you're laying out and trying to
claim countries at the very beginning of
the game which country should you go
for which continents should you try and
take over Brady you're from Australia so
Australia is an interesting case because
here the continent only has four
different countries so it's very quick
you can control
that but it doesn't generate very much
because australasia only generates two
armies per turn although you can get it
quite quickly doesn't generate much
whilst Asia will take quite a long time
to just fill those and you might be
competing with another player so to
control that whole continent you'll be
rewarded with seven armies per turn one
important thing here is to use a little
bit of mathematics which is the
mathematics of topology because actually
it doesn't really matter what the map of
the world looks like it's how the map is
connected because you'll be able to try
and Conquer another country on your turn
if there's a border between a country
you're on and a country your opponent's
on so let's take Iceland so the white
Army on their turn could try and take
over the the blue Army on Greenland
because there's a connection here but
obviously I can only compete in this
case against countries that I'm
connected to so one of the important
things is how are these continents and
countries connected both America and
Europe if you control those continents
they both generate Five Armies if you
control them but does one of these have
an advantage to to occupy and I did a
little new version of the map of the
world and this is a a topological map
which just shows the connections between
the countries what's interesting is that
actually Europe is connected to a lot of
under continents so there are a lot of
ways that Europe can be attacked so
Europe is actually much more vulnerable
than America which turns out actually to
have um three from this side and
actually there's another side because
you can be attacked from from Oh Yes
actually I've got this in because it's
Asia can attack so kind of interestingly
that's the beauty of a topology you
don't have to worry about the layout
it's just how they're connected so
America turns out to be a better
continent to go for because of the
topological map map of the world which
is actually difficult to see if you're
just looking at the geographical map so
I would suggest Asia is quite hard to
occupy a lot of countries America I
would say is the best place to go for I
can see why that would Mak America
easier to defend defend yes does it does
it not make America less ideal for
launching
attack you you picked up a really
interesting question about risk for many
years it was thought that it was easier
to win this game if you just sit and
defend but you've got to attack
sometimes cuz you're going to try and uh
take over the world but on any
particular turn is it better to sit and
soak up attacks or is it actually
strategically better to go on the
offensive well so how do you actually
attack so let's suppose Greenland with
three armies is going to attack Iceland
with two and so you determine this with
the throw of dice so Greenland gets to
throw three dice for its three armies
Iceland is defending with its two dice
why don't you be Iceland okay uh and so
uh I'm going to attack Iceland and so we
both throw all of our dice so there's my
three dice um of six six and a four so
now you're going to defend so throw your
two dice and so that's a five and a four
now what you do is you peel off the top
dice in each of our roles so my six
beats your five so you lose an army for
that one m and then we go down to the
second and my six beats your four and so
you lose a second Army and now I can
invade but what happen suppose you got a
six for example then the six would match
my six and You' be safe and then this
six would beat your five and I would
just take one
Army so you keep on playing until one of
the countries is wiped out so the
question is like well I've got three
dice against your two but I have got to
beat your dice so the question is you
know okay so I've got to get more than
the throws on your dice the Dynamics of
this quite interesting and again this
uses a a piece of mathematics which
comes up again and again in playing
games we see it in Snakes and Ladders we
see it in uh Monopoly it's something
called The markof Matrix which is the
state of the armies now depends only on
the state before that not you know three
throws before so you can actually use a
matrix which records the probability
that given I've got three armies and
you've got two um what's the probability
we're going to go down to me with three
and you with one me with three and you
with zero me with two and you with two
and so this Matrix records all the
different possibilities of what the
armies might look like after the throw
of the dice but the first analysis of
this turned out to be wrong because
people didn't realize that there a
dependence in the way the dice are being
thrown very often when you're working
out probability you know if I throw one
dice it somehow is not going to affect
the throw of the other dice so they're
independent so the chance of getting two
sixes well there one and a six chance
that I get a six with one dice and one
over six so the combined chance of me
getting uh two sixes you multiply the
probabilities together and so it's a one
in a 36 chance of getting two sixes so
that's clear so you think these things
are completely independent but actually
when you're comparing dice there be
begins to be a dependence in working out
the probabilities and this had been
missed this dependence so um dependence
in probability is very important and so
the first analysis of the mathematics of
risk said actually it's an advantage to
defend that you're more likely to hold
on to your country if you're defending
but this misss that actually there's a
dependence in the dice because if the
second dice here is a five that means
the top dice must have been a five or a
six so the second dice actually
influences what must have been in the
top Dice and this was kind of missed if
you got a one here the top dice can be
very many things if it's a five the top
dice only has two possibilities so this
creates a dependence when you're
comparing Dice and so when the
mathematics was calculated with this
dependence put inside the transition
Matrix turns out now that you're an
advantage in this game if you actually
attack other
countries this has actually changed the
Dynamics of the game and and it's
interesting that this kind of dependence
of probabilities had been missed in this
game because you're comparing guys
they're not independent I get emailed
about risk quite a lot and I've never
played it and never known what the game
is now that you've shown me I understand
why I get lots of emails it Le seems
very methy what what I think is um
interesting is the um when this game was
developed and I think it was developed
by um a French
filmmaker there would have been a lot of
kind of beta testing because uh you want
to work out well you know the topology
of the map will be important you can
find that one country will always be
winning I think actually it's always uh
you find austral Asia because of its
isolation and the small number is never
a good continent to sort of occupy the
there are some dominant ones which are
Asia Europe and America so it's it's
really a sort of three-player game with
those we're quite happy being safe down
there don't yeah that's true yeah
exactly but I think this subtlety and it
you know took a uh actually a long time
for the mathematics to really be teased
out um shows that this is a beautifully
balanced game because whether you're
aggressive or defensive um it was really
unclear which one was was going to be
the optimal strategy but um now the
mathematics seems to say that being
offensive is the best way to win this
game what's your playing style when you
play Risk well now it's being influenced
by the mathematics and that's I think
what's intriguing is that you know
because I love playing games and I love
unpicking the mathematics that hides
behind that game um it will often
influence how I play so another game I
love is Ticket to Ride which is about um
uh laying down uh railway tracks across
America America and and you get given
challenges you know should you do a long
one from New York to Los Angeles or or
maybe a short one and again the Dynamics
of that game rewards risk so of course a
long trying to claim a long track um
will require a lot more sort of gaming
however the rewards if you can do that
are such that you will probably win the
game so again my analysis shows that I
want to take the risks and not go for
the short ones but go for the big long
ones
risk is one of many games well in fact
80 games covered in Marcus's latest book
Around the World in 80 games find out
more information from the link in the
video description you can also support
number file on patreon you see a list of
some of our supporters on screen at the
moment there's often little bonus things
going on in fact hundreds and hundreds
of our patrons recently received a
unique prime number in the post just
like this it's a great way to support
our project again there'll there a link
in the description if you're interested